[Music]
there are plenty of games that have
specific moves that are nicknamed by
their communities
whether it's siege or league of legends
hugh's in
ward's back kicks in that is so hard to
execute
players around the globe often race each
other to be the first to discover them
and in some cases these mechanical
contributions have seen certain players
become
forever immortalized by their game's
community
oh do an insect oh kicks him back what's
the
oh no oh he does get him on the edge of
the shock wave the barrier goes down
though both of what they're holding
and he sticks out his big toe and gets
the kill under pobelter now only a
select few
innovators have managed to do this but
for many of them it is the ultimate
compliment to receive
you can pick
santa speak in rocket league you've
probably heard of maneuvers like the
cucks or pinch
a fire burner 50 50 or a doomsie dish
but nobody has left their mark quite
like
musty rocket league's undisputed king of
content creation
a player who etched his name into the
game's history books by developing one
of its most
useful mechanics the musty flick
stellar musty flick by the mosty cow
himself so
how is it that one signature move was
able to kickstart musty's entire career
as a content creator and how did he use
it as a launching pad
to play alongside some of his idols
listen man like if you guys ever need
like a sub like for the professional
team
like i'm always down if you have
you thought loser
okay so before we jump into the video if
you guys would really love to
score a goal with the score esports
please please please
hit the sub button like the video and
make sure you turn on notifications so
you never miss it when a new episode
goes live
so other than being rocket league's most
subbed to
youtuber who is this 20 year old
mastermind from georgia well before
musti began humiliating kids in 1v1s
he played soccer for his local club and
high school
but it wasn't until 2016 that he was
introduced to the game
that would change his life forever my
brother he is two years older than me he
was
at the same high school i was at he also
played soccer as well every soccer
tournament you go to every
you know there's always fifa at your
friend's house after the tournament or
after after the game but one of his
friends you know had rocket league that
just came out he told me about it
and you know he downloaded the game
right after i decided to play
and i almost quit because it's a very
hard game to
learn now musty enjoyed his brief
introduction to rocket league
but because soccer was his main priority
the vehicular version of the beautiful
game
ended up taking a backseat but that same
year
something happened to musti that forced
him to rethink his entire future
basically i got a concussion and i
couldn't obviously couldn't play soccer
again with concussion
and even though you're not really
supposed to play like video games with a
concussion
you know i don't want to stare at like a
black room for
you know every single hour of the day so
my mom let me play like
some video games and i recently like
discovered rocket league
and i really kind of fell in love with
it and i decided to kind of quit soccer
like right at the beginning of high
school
and just played rocket league for at the
time you know just for fun
musty managed to make light of a pretty
shitty situation
and his unfortunate injury actually
ended up being a blessing in disguise
although he missed competing in soccer
rocket league offered him a chance to
play a game
that at the most basic level mirrored
the sport's fundamentals
without exposing him to the risk of
another concussion
that was like my true passion and i was
like so sad like i couldn't do it even
though like i definitely could have like
come back and everything i just felt
like
you know it was time to kind of give it
a change because i played club soccer
and then
high school soccer you just i don't know
i was smaller than everyone too at the
time i was like 14 year old like playing
against all these 18 year olds like
elbowing me accidentally when they're
running you know it's it's it wasn't as
fun getting
injured musty was falling more and more
in love with rocket league
and as he became more adept at the game
he began sharing some of his highlights
on reddit
but it was a mechanic that he discovered
in october of 2016
that left the entire community
dumbfounded now at first glance it
seemed
relatively simple to understand but if
you've ever actually played rocket
league
you'll know that that's rarely the case
the technique requires the player to
tilt the nose of their car
forward so it goes beyond a 90 degree
angle with the pitch
before backflipping if the ball is
sitting in the sweet spot
on the hood of your car then you will
generate plenty of momentum when
releasing the shot
now this might sound easy to some of you
but it can take
hundreds of hours to master and is
totally worth it because in many cases
specifically in 1v1 situations it can be
extremely hard to defend against now the
value of musty's technique was
clear as day to rocket league die hards
who became
consumed by their desire to learn it but
first
they wanted to know what it was called i
had some people ask me to
pick a name for this new mechanic and i
jokingly said the musty flick
and i thought there's no way we would
actually end up calling this new
mechanic the musty flick but
other people started calling it that and
the name somehow stuck
but as musty continued to mesmerize
players with reddit clips of his
technique in action
it wasn't long before his discovery was
being replicated and
recognized by the game's pro scene and
farah too far back he has to wait for
flakes
flakes musty flick and it's good
and in april of 2018 musty finally gave
rocket league scrubs what they had long
been begging for
a tutorial you can probably tell the
move is basically just a forward-facing
backflip
you just jump up tilt your car forward
and then backflip after posting his
tutorial musty began
rapidly growing as a content creator but
he wanted to push himself
even further he wanted to become the
biggest rocket league youtuber on the
block but in order to do so
he would have to compete with one of the
community's biggest stars
sunless khan so on december 31st 2019
musty and his rival sunless set out on a
race to see who could hit a million
subscribers on youtube first
now sunless started the race with a
whopping 125
000 subscriber lead but in may of 2020
musty somehow managed to surpass him
you know me and someone sweetest like
banter a lot on twitter you know have
some fun
so i i kind of i truly believe in like
manifestation i think i think that's
word for it of like
oh no so i just wanted to put it in the
writing on on my twitter
that like uh i will hit a million subs
by the end of the year because
i truly believe that helps like it's
like you have to hold yourself up to it
at that point
and uh so much just reply to it he's
like hey
race me bro both creators decided that
whoever hit the milestone first would
receive a
thousand dollars from the loser and
musty was quick to start promoting the
race on his own channel
fans were starting to show up daily to
watch him stream his wacky content on
twitch
but they were also watching to hear his
insight into
level play gonna flick he's gonna save
i thought he was gonna say yeah he saved
it it's a little a little awkward in the
jump
trying to bump here we do get the bump
we get the goal
over this period of time musty had
become pretty damn good at rocket league
he no longer felt outclassed by the
game's best players
and soon enough was playing alongside
them and the relationships that he
formed with some of his idols
pushed him even closer to his sub goal
but in september of 2020
he received help in a pretty big way
musty was unveiled as a content creator
for nrg
and they immediately started promoting
his race against
sunless he joined a long list of
internet personalities and professional
players
who already represented the prestigious
org and on september 14th
only two weeks after signing with nrg
musty finally reached his goal of 1
million subscribers yeah joining nrg is
def
definitely probably the biggest you know
i made it moment and then
i was like 980 000 subs when i joined
energy so like
pretty much right after that i hit a
million energy even helped me you know
hit a million as well you know they kind
of promoted the race and everything
which was cool
but it was one player in particular who
made musty's decision to join nrg
an easy one it definitely was mainly
just squishy like i used to watch his
like road to grand champ series back in
the day
and that definitely like gave me the
initial spark to like take the game
instead of just a casual game to kind of
take it more seriously and try to grind
it out which
i've never really done that with the
game before but you know it was well
worth it
so i've looked up a squishy for so long
went from cloud9 to nrg
and nrg offered me a spot like after
that
you know as a content creator and uh
especially because squishy was there
squishy uh you know huge inspiration and
uh
garrett justin both very good players as
well that's you know very hard to say no
to
and i'm really glad i made that decision
because it's been a blast so far
and even though he defeated sunless in
their quests to a million subs
he cannot thank his rival enough for
pushing him to become the game's
most successful youtuber you know behind
the scenes you know we're really good
friends and i feel like most of viewers
knew that and
it definitely did help both of us a ton
and even more recently
in march nrg announced musty as the
team's
substitute although he likely won't be
seeing play anytime
soon he can be seen grinding on twitch
daily
trying to become one of the game's best
players
i think i did a chat i think i did a
musty flick without even looking at
that game
oh my word oh my word 360 quick scope
hard for me to get the straight on that
so we can try a little pinch
[Music]
oh my god who knows maybe musty can be
the next youtuber who makes it big as a
pro player he plays against some of the
best players in the world on a daily
basis and by doing so
he now realizes just how similar
high-level rocket league practice
is to traditional sports especially in
in
gaming like you can put in a lot more
hours than you can in like traditional
soccer just because you know you don't
really get as tired like
you know mentally you get tired after
like you know a long time
of playing but there's so many
similarities of like you know keeping
possession of the ball you know always
doing something
uh just putting the hours into the game
you know there's so many similarities
and
i've really recently kind of found that
same drive like you know trying to
improve
in rock lagina that was the same drive
as i was trying to improve in soccer
but rocket league games only feature
five minutes of regulation time
and chances come and go in a matter of
seconds
[Applause]
staying focused and becoming a
consistent competitor
at the highest level of play is not
something that a lot of people can do
but musty hopes to one day maintain the
level of intensity of some of the
world's
best i feel like in other games like you
have like some like
time where you can take a chill pill
like your team you know has got you or
something but in rocky
if you blink too too long like you get
scored on it's like one of those games
you have to be
on your a game at all times and i'm
trying to perfect that right now after
losing his passion in life to injury
musty transformed himself into rocket
league's biggest
youtuber and with his channel now
sitting at nearly two and a half
million subs he's showing no signs of
slowing down
and who knows maybe one day we will see
musty grace the pitch of the rlcs
as a starter for nrg it's an honor to to
be a part of the team
you know get a you know the pro status
title you know it's it's super cool
you know if they ever do need me or you
know maybe you know school she could cut
his power cable or something i feel like
it would be fun and like a non-important
map you know to see how
i would do it but you know it's cool
it's cool
oh my god oh my god someone clip someone
cups i'm like
i've actually put i've only played
rocket league a few times and
uh i'm pretty bad at it i'm just like a
pylon dude
they get my it's like playing 1v3 it was
bad
score goal score a goal yeah okay
this is why i'm not riding dude yeah
that's rough i kind of want to do it
though so cringe
i kind of want to do it